this is not good enough okay t-series is
taking over India is taking over the
European Union approved the banning of
millions article 13 this meant for
Germany
it's the Germans again huh I didn't want
to make any kind of jokes like that but
this time they're back I try to warn you
guys first they take our freedom then
they take our meat no wait whatever you
understand what you understand the
stakes I've had enough
okay that's the face you make when you
troll the enemy that's the face of pure
evil right there that's the top boss I'm
sorry you have to tongue out like that
so you know it's so business what we
need here is a country not affiliated
with European we need another country to
mean what have we got Russia of course
yeah you like that okay let's go a
normal day in Russia dealing with a
parking spot dispute I've seen this I've
never shared my show
[Music]
just saw that voting I mean that car
nobody's saved what I like I was talking
like it's taking matters in your own
hand you don't go and ban memes or
anything like that I like it a plus for
the safety glasses when the guy behind
you keeps hitting the chair I love this
so much
at that moment Victor knew he had messed
up big time what happened to Victor he
tricked so random and like why is he on
a bus Russia is so random guys they just
went on buses may imagine like a bot you
wouldn't see Obama or Trump or whatever
on a bus like this what's the content
what happened to Victor look at his
friend is looking at like damn you did
not just do that
Victor you messed up big time boy even
here take a seat
[Music]
hey perfect just realise when I was in
Japan we wrote a the subway a lie and
people kept falling asleep it happened a
couple times people would fall asleep on
my shoulder and I was like ah that's
cute now I realized they were just
trying to get rid of me
dad life hack that's pretty good
see we have a lot that we can learn from
Russia their way of dealing with
problems is a plus I gotta say very nice
when you have a car crash just entertain
yourself build some snowmen although if
they were truly a progressive country
they would build snow when I guess some
could you still have a way to go mm-hmm
this can't be real
why are there so many putin memes like
what is he doing hey look she's rockin
the latest Gucci fashion look at her why
is he always everywhere how can you be
so me mobile I understand that they just
split the pictures around okay I
understand this is Putin just normally
licking his lollipop as you do and then
he decided nicely to give it to the kid
some jerk try to just switch them around
but then you have the face of the kid
and it's like what the heck oh look at
that kids face is incredible I really
want to know what he see what did potent
tell that child to make himself
I need a SOT moving on that face when
Putin off for some tea
why won't you have his tea pour potent
no one wants his tea have some tea
no thanks I wasn't asking his residue
probably poisoned the tea that could be
it they probably knew man like Putin
always poisons the tea drink tea you
guys opposition activists arrested while
reporting live about arrests of
opposition activists say they got a
great sense of humor
that's hilarious look at the guy he
looks so sad oh no this is definitely
not funny but also very funny
my favorite kind of humor you're like
you have you have something very
upsetting but you can still laugh at it
you have something upset upsetting and
wrong with the world but it still makes
you chuckle and you move about with your
day that's the kind of jokes I prefer
analog ATM in Russia see they got great
banks
look at that dude he looks wonderful hey
what some money no problem just give me
your credit card number back in front
okay here you go here's a fiver on
Russian television they photoshopped the
smile of King Yong Ying that is it oh
well okay so this is the first picture
and I see actual picture they use one of
those face fill tanks you know where
they give anyone a smile the phase app
or whatever - Putin everywhere now this
is kind of freaking me out
Russian watch done
[Music]
whoa
what what is happening why is it normal
to have a Barris pet in Russia and Blanc
is really in Russian well it looks like
I'm not going to Russia then a normal
day in president's life there there you
go again
what does he do all day he broke his arm
he's too bad old Putin memes i swear to
god he's writing a suicide note for him
because he can't write with his left
hand so thoughtful of him so that is so
wholesome guys smash like on this video
that is so nice last famine sandy wait
there's women in russia less than how
well oh my god
[Music]
all right summary in Russia why is
everyone in Russia wearing the latest
Gucci collection I don't understand how
can they afford it all right don't make
me feel for people too much let's move
on so stupid why don't we laugh at these
Russian TV everybody well at least I
don't have any ads take a Hollywood in
Russia who says Russia is not high-class
like the California leaves look at that
I can't tell the difference don't you
take my parking spot ok 8:35 9:30 you
could have just moved the bike why move
the bike when you can throw it up a tree
yay all right
note to self don't ever make a wrong
parking in Russia got it ok what's the
name of this country what I've seen this
[Music]
my favorite it's the guy on the lower
left who's only angry and wants to fight
the guy crew in the hill then his buddy
comes like no kidding they're fine
come on to you there okay let's keep
hanging out in the container kiddo we're
having a good time Kira come on we're
doing the slug dance is that a real
wedding photo this is some indian level
photoshop man damn she looks so happy
about the marriage
has anyone ever smile in a photo in
Russia you just got to get the phase
that that's how the only way whenever
there's in a smiling in Russian photos
you know they use Photoshop Stadium in
Russia didn't need to be fun : vacation
for the World Cup so they added 18,000
seats in the most terrifying way
possible do you see anything from this
seat Oh what you dude you do okay well
Belarus ever anyone Russia will arrest
your trash recycling it's a subversive
capitalist plot if you pee we'll put you
on YouTube wait some Russians actually
fear this before you're allowed in the
tank you have to prove you're blind
trust in it no no whoa
just imagine the cannon just firing the
the candidates they finish them off they
mastered the fashion game no one can
deny it
well that's enough Fiat for me for today
check out the merch guys just kidding
you can't we sold out keep subscribing
we need to destroy India and that's it
for me for now leave like and enjoyed
this video and I'll see you guys
tomorrow
get out and now a word from our sponsor
if anyone comments negatively about my
camera setup you will 100% be banned
yeah it's time for me to flex on your
kids very nice I have the honor play and
the new honor of 10 very nice thank you
honor for sponsoring this video I of
course already have the old one and look
at this by the way music my queen
my king very nice but it's time for me
to utter brain because now I have the
honor play everybody let's start by
unboxing the honor play unboxing time
smash like if you like unboxing well I
guess here it is already we didn't even
have to unbox it how about that now
what's special about the other play is
new well many things but it's optimized
for gaming so it's got GPU turbo which
basically means improved graphics
performance increasing efficiency with
60% damn Daniel basically while you're
playing video games you'll get a stable
performance no lag no BS it also has an
amazing battery on my old one is already
amazing like I feel like I rarely even
have to charge it
so if they've improved on that even more
that that's not bad son you can
apparently stream 15 hours of video on
this you can watch 15 hours of PewDiePie
on this ok if that's not epic I don't
know what is 95 hours of music you can
even watch if you use the ultra power
saving mode by honors power saving
technology a full season of Rick and
Morty or your favorite TV show doesn't
have to be written Maury I just assumed
it was written morning in one charge I
forgot to mention that otherwise it
wouldn't be that impressive so the
graphics processing quality is higher
frame rate lower jitter so you'll be
able to play games like pub G they have
3d surround sound and smart shock so if
you get shot anywhere the phone will
vibrate in their direction of their
bullets and you'll be able to
distinctively that's a tough word for me
apparently be able to hear where the
shots are coming from which obviously if
you're playing a game like pub G or any
competitive game on your phone that's a
must so you'll have a major advantage
with a phone like the honor play so I
haven't tried out the camera but it's
supposed to have AI technology
recognizes 500 more and more scenarios
since the settings based on it damn I
look good
damn I look good it also has a are lens
oh yeah
[Music]
this changes everything how I eat it oh
man has a lot of them hey guys I'm just
in London I also have to show you my
honor 10 damn can you see their
reflections it's not lit enough damn it
it's super cool
it looks amazing I love the look of this
phone so this one is very similar to the
honor play very eye-catching very nice
and looking so this one has GPU turbo as
well now to show you the power of Flex
tape and the power of the honor we're
gonna do a dent benchmark test okay this
is that big so let's let's cut to that
okay here's a benchmark test between
honor play one plus six and Samsung S
nine plus these are the settings that we
used and we write a MOBA game on it and
as you can see honored place stays at 60
frames per second steady while on one
plus six and Samsung against nine is
going all over the place which means you
will get starting and lag while playing
a game which you especially don't want
so here you can see the result 100%
stability and honor plays version 90% in
1 plus 85 on the sensor okay so on a
plane obviously the best choice
everybody